salut le jour est venu aujourd'hui de
tourner cette toute première vidéo dans
mon nouveau studio nouveau studio
parisien donc ça c'est cool on en
reparle dans quelques jours pour
l'instant on se concentre pour tout
autre chose on parle d'un produit peu
tendues depuis un petit moment on se
dépasse il allait arriver en france et
tout compte fait il est là c'est
celui-là ce petit prix dollar et
l'économie des mots c'est le au nord 20
pro alors le haut-rhin pouget déjà bien
évidemment tu es ma vie je me tais style
et la regarder juste là dans la maille
est très sympa et sonore un pro il a
plein de belles qualités fait des
promesses qu'ils sont très intéressantes
maintenant la question c'est est ce
qu'il est ce qu'il va les tenir
est ce qu'il est en capacité de les
tenir et au final est-ce que ceux au
nord 20 provost le coup oui non quoi
commencer ça tout de suite dans ce
premier texte
premier test j'ai du mal à le cas on se
sent aujourd'hui dans ce premier test
depuis mon nouveau studio par les ags
croyez moi c'est plutôt cool
[Musique]
l'année dernière on a déjà pas mal
parler du bonheur dit ce qui était un
smartphone cool avec plein de belles
qualités très intéressant hélas cette
année j'étais un peu frustré de pas voir
le au nord 20 pro qui est un peu le le
modèle le plus haut de gamme de chez au
nord à ce moment là en tout cas il ya eu
aux normes on en a déjà parlé il ya eu
au nord 20 lite on a également déjà
parlé que j'attendais vraiment ce
modèle-là pour pouvoir en parler en
parler plus en détails vous dire ce que
j'en pensais au final parler de son
placement parce que c'est un produit qui
était intéressant oui non pas comment je
suis très content aujourd'hui nous
pouvons la voir ici de prendre le temps
de le tester et de vous dire s'il
intéressant alors ce que je vous propose
c'est qu'on regarde là j'ai un peu la
partie design prise en main il informa
qu'une vache moins intéressant et puis
la plainte derrière dessus ont été des
années au niveau de la boîte on n'a pas
un truc extraordinaire ça fonctionne
c'est plutôt bien
un grand classique un peu ce qu'on peut
retrouver chez honore sa marche et bien
scellé dans cette très sympathique vous
avez un bac de recharge rapide plutôt
pas mal qui permet de recharger
rapidement mais ça on en parle d'ici
quelques instants
bien évidemment vous avez de la recharge
en usb type c'est ça vous vous en
douterez mais surtout le truc est pas
mal c'est que vous avez un adaptateur
usb sévère puisque déjà car je sais pas
si c'est bien et pas bien parce que ça
veut dire que sur le smartphone vous
n'arrive pas de prise jack
donc ça c'est des fois un peu le le pan
de regrets ici vous n'avez absolument
aucune prise jack
nulle part vous y donc vous contenter
d'un haut parleur on parle en mono qui
est situé juste en bas is it qui dans
l'absolu marche pas trop mal sa race et
ça fonctionne plutôt bien vous n'avez
pas de haut parleurs stéréo ici l'eau
par leur soin l'eau vous ne pouvez pas
l'utiliser pour écouter de la musique
c'est peut-être un petit point de regret
après tu te trompes vachement bien
c'est ici le capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui est située sur le côté je
trouve vraiment bien extrêmement rapide
au nord nous avons annoncé un
déverrouillage 0 la ville trois secondes
et croyez moi c'est vraiment bien c'est
raté précis moi je trouve ça vraiment
cool ça c'est vraiment vraiment bien
vous avez bien évidemment ici votre
bouton de volume 5 août et qui mange
bien pour moi après c'est un grand stand
arroser votre micro plat réduction de
bruit là votre haut-parleurs votre usb
type c'est ici le coin pour la carte sim
ici vous avez votre micro une croupe à
réduction de bruit le micro en haïti si
l inverse pas tout vous avez ici de
l'infrarouge pour l'utiliser comme une
télécommande la partie photo vidéo n'en
parlera ultérieurement dans une
prochaine vidéo de gravité maintenant
vous avez si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
puis surtout c'est un smartphone que moi
je trouve vraiment
très très très très très très beau vous
avez un design holographique vous avez
trois couches qui ont été faites ici
donc l'effet que ça vous donne quand
même cet effet deux voiliers de de
logram un petit peu qui est très très
très sympa me sens vraiment chouette
vous avez un dos en verre ici plutôt
bien alors il va prendre quelques traces
de doigts ça c'est ce qu'on retrouve un
peu classique en va pas on va pas trop
lui en vouloir moi je trouve bien j'aime
bien cette couleur un petit peu le
mélange de deux mois il ya un peu de
violence intérieure j'aime beaucoup je
sens vraiment très très très très sympa
surtout ce que jamais sur ce smartphone
c'est la prise en main vous prenez très
facilement dans la main et a très
facilement pouvez naviguer facilement à
une main à demain vous jouerez un peu
plus la question de la sécurité
mais en tout cas moi je trouve ça
vraiment cool comme il est là voyez vous
pourrez naviguer facilement ça pour moi
c'est vraiment top on a donc un produit
qui est vraiment cool en termes de
design qui est très jolie belle réussite
belle prise en main jusque là c'est un
sans faute sous serre vraiment cool
après on va se poser la question
justement de la partie de l'écran vous
avez l'écran de 6,26 pouces de diagonale
que ton montre plutôt bien et surtout ce
que nous annoncer au nord là dessus
c'est qu'il tient dans la main comme un
smartphone de 5,3 pouces donc là on a
effectivement tout l'intérêt d'avoir un
form factor un peu petit puis d'avoir un
grand écran ça c'est du grâce au fait de
pouvoir avoir cette petite encoche cette
petite bulle je sais que mon rôle
d'écrire est ici malheureusement n'aura
pas d'écran oled ont un écran lcd mais
que par contre je trouve vraiment bien
et bien calibrés
vous pouvez y dans vos paramètres vous a
aidé en affichage vous avez donc confort
des yeux moi j'ai activé le confort des
yeux c'est à dire que ça va venir me
venir un petit peu ça va casser cette
lumière bleue vous le mettez un petit
peu près voulu régler comme vous voulez
pour moi vous le mettez juste comme ça
vous venez cas c'est un petit peu le le
côté lumière bleue c'est vraiment bien
ça vient adoucir l'écran c'est vraiment
pratique est le deuxième point qui est
pas mal c'est enfin c'est déjà par
défaut c'est la résolution de l'écran
qui est intelligente vous avez la
résolution de maxime a tout de suite qui
en 2003 140 par 1080 pixels c'est la
résolution élevée mais lorsque vous
allez voir un peu moins de batterie pour
venir gagner en autonomie vous allez
pouvoir switcher directement hd + 1560
par 720 pixels
pourquoi pas je trouve ça pas mal en
tout cas ça s'écoute un peu intéressant
qu'on va retrouver avec cet os là là
vous le voyez magic johan 2.1.0 et vous
êtes basé en plus vers l'android neufs
le tout marche parfaitement bien parce
que oui là dessus on à android parce que
oui si vous avez suivi actif près vous
savez qui est des soucis il ya eu des
soucis en tout cas entre les us et la
chine comment
mais passé ce aux normes froid les
sortir à cause de ça on ait eu l'honneur
grâce à c'était bien été certifié
absolument aucun problème et l'otan fin
proche et pas trop donc du coup il a
fini par arriver
ça c'est la très bonne nouvelle voyons
dans android 9 vous êtes tranquille et à
mon avis on va continuer à gagner de
l'android pour l'instant tout cas sur
les smartphone huawei et au nord alors
même si huawei nous a annoncé avoir son
lot est propriétaire on en parlera une
prochaine fois pour l'instant vous êtes
tranquille vous pouvez aller sur des
produits comme ça vous aurez les mises à
jour ils ont la licence google à essence
qu'android vous êtes tranquille donc ça
s'est vraiment bien
le dauphin progression des premiers
regarder des vidéos alors le seul truc
que je regrette un peu dans cet écran
c'est dans son adn en tout cas c'est le
fait d'avoir ce petit trou ici pour
loger la caméra alors avant qu'on ait
des caméras complètement situé sous
l'écran fin 2019 2020 pour l'instant
deux encore en avoir là alors c'est un
alternative
vous avez aussi petite caméra pop up
c'est en tout cas c'est plutôt pas mal
c'est pas très grave dans l'absolu on
finit rapidement par l'oublier mais
c'est vrai quand on prend comme ça on en
sait un peu moyen mais bon voilà on s'y
fait à côté de ça je trouve vraiment
bien je trouve l'écran assez lu mineurs
allaient là j'ai poussé à fond je trouve
assez lumineux pour me regarder du
contenu vidéo toutes vos séries hbo
films ce que vous les volutes tu as
préféré me sucre qui vous voulez ça
c'est cool c'est vachement confort bon
maintenant il va te coucher moi un peu
moins fans c est la partie audio je
trouve que ça marche ou bien dans
l'absolu mais ce que j'aurais aimé ce
que je regrette un peu c'est le fait
d'avoir justement ce petit haut parleur
mono qui se situe là ça y'a pas
sensation d'immersion alors après on est
sur un smartphone qui est un tarif hyper
agressive donc il a fallu faire des
choix stratégiques de la part d' honneur
donc ça se comprend mais néanmoins
j'aurais quand même aimé pouvoir
retrouver du côté un peu parleurs stéréo
pour un peu plus d'immersion même si
c'est jamais parfait quelle que soit la
solution sauf haut parleurs en façade de
chaque côté comme du côté de chez google
met le guen pixels 3 est ce que vous
pouvez retrouvez aussi sur certains
smartphones de gaby bon voilà ça c'est
petit aparté à côté de ça si vous
l'écoutez comme ça vous avez quand même
assez de puissance sur le haut-parleur
du bas donc ça vous délivre un son qui
est assez puissant on va pas voir un
spectre de fou on est petit on parle de
smartphones dont il faut raison garder
mais ça marche plutôt pas mal et si
toutefois vous voulez avoir un casque et
vous prenez comme je vous le disais
c'est accessoire là alors bon c'est bien
qu'il existe je suis pas hyper un père
fan parce que lorsque vous l'avez comme
ça voyez vous êtes toutes et un truc qui
pendouille basset s'est jamais parfait
vous voyez vous baladez vous dans les
transports en commun avec un sa bonté
prix vois pas trop l'intérêt
à noter que moi dans ma boîte j'ai une
boîte presse donc n'est pas d'écouteurs
usb c'est pour venir écouter la musique
directement avec le petit casse ça je
peux pas le faire mais vous si vous
l'achetez vous l'aurez ça c'est cool ça
vous évitera d'utiliser petit accessoire
sauf si vous avez déjà un casque avec
une prise jack
voilà mais bon pas l'absolue sachez que
vous avez un petit casque est intégré
directement intérieur donc ça c'est
aussi plutôt pas mal et maintenant
qu'elle est il de la partie performance
parce que vous avez quand même ce qui se
fait mieux du côté de chez huawei honor
c'est à dire vous avez un kirin 980 vous
avez ici du lmp eu vous avez 8 gigas de
ram
après l'alto 456 go de stockage on a une
machine qui est très bien très rapide
fluide vraiment agréable pour toute la
partie et me moi je trouve vraiment bien
car vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment
fluide ça c'est vraiment cool assez
kirin 980 ça marche quand même super
bien je suis absolument rien à redire
fait d'avoir eu 8 gigas de ram derrière
sa porte de la fluidité donc c'est vrai
que sur un public sera pas usurpée ubg
comme vous et où j'avais tout cas
ramassage est pas pris eh bien écoutez
je trouve que c'est vachement confort
c'est vraiment agréable ça ne lag pas
j'ai pas de problème c'est cool j'ai pu
caler trouver des gens et hop leur
mettre des petites balles dans la tête
parce qu'ils sont pas très gentils avec
moi mais sinon je trouve ça voilà plutôt
cool bonne expérience machine qui est
fluide
tout ça c'est bien alors après tout ce
que j'ai pu retrouver un certain moment
c'est que je trouvais qui chauffait un
petit peu c'est pas bien grave ça
chauffe et légèrement ici donc là
j'avais une partie qui était un peu plus
chaudes à côté de ça j'ai une
dissipation de la chaleur qui est assez
bonne
jean refroidissement qui fait à base de
graphène ça m'a pas vraiment dérangé
dans la bouche tout ça plutôt cool et ça
me réchauffe un peu mal donc pour les
longues soirées d'hiver ça peut
peut-être être bien c'est pas très grave
mais je vous dis une fois de plus pour
jouer les faibles ji hwan nom de zeus
ils sont par là pour jouer à du peuple j
ça marche parfaitement bien tous les
jeux que vous voulez c'est aussi un
partenariat avec fortnight conduit la
peau nue gaming performances vous ne
serez absolument pas déçu avec le au
nord 20 propres en plus de ça vous avez
déjà pu turbo 3.0 qu'une famille de
quatre
santes images par seconde je trouve ça
plutôt honnête je suis trouvé un score
sur entre tous de 200 4221 ce qui doit
évoluer quand même plutôt pas mal
nathan qu'en est-il de la question de
l'autonomie alors sur ce modèle là vous
avez une grosse batterie de 4000
milliampères heures ça c'est plutôt bien
donc ça vous permet quand même de tenir
alors après ça dépend bien sûr des
usages mais pour moi vous pouvez garder
deux jours vous êtes plutôt cool si vous
bourriner joué beaucoup et bien
fatalement ça va baisser et par contre
ce qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
que vous avez un chargeur 22,5 soit pour
être très précis
sanaa le recharger extrêmement
rapidement c'est que en une demi-heure
de charges vous allez pouvoir leur monte
à 50% ce qui fait que il agit les bains
vous jouez beaucoup de films journée
complète vous avez beaucoup utilisé le
lendemain vous êtes parti voulait pas
rechargez vos visas s'accroissent un
petit peu là pour amener ma journée
eh bien vous trouvez une petite demi
heure au bureau à la fac
chez bout en faisant la sieste enfin ce
qui vous fait plaisir ça c'est vous qui
choisissez tout simple et bien vous avez
une petite demi-heure en vous le
branchez vous êtes reparti pour une
journée pour ce facile donc ça c'est
vraiment intéressant et c'est tout
l'intérêt en tout cas d'un produit comme
celui là c'est que bien vous avez de la
performance vous avez un produit qui est
bien qui vous permettra pas mal de
choses et qui est endurant et si
toutefois vous ne pensez pas à recharger
et bien ces recharges et extrêmement
rapidement donc ça c'est vraiment cool
ah bravo au nord toute la partie photo
je vous en parle dans quelques jours
j'ai plein de choses à dire dessus il ya
plein de capteur photo de tous les
volets donc ça c'est vraiment faire une
vidéo dédiée qu'on prenne le temps je
veux partir quelques jours à chamonix
donc je vais l'emmener avec moi et fait
shooter plein de choses ce film est
comme ça je vous en parlais plus en
détails d'ici quelques jours en
attendant c'est un smartphone que moi je
trouve vraiment intéressant parce que si
vous voulez de la puissance si vous
voulez un truc lui si vous voulez une
machine un peu passe partout si vous
voyez une la bonne autonomie
eh bien vous avez un excellent
smartphone alors effectivement comme je
vous le disais il ya des choix qui ont
été faits par au nord il ya un écran lcd
il n'y a pas d'écran oled d'un côté
c'est un smartphone qui vendent ou tarif
de 599 euros
tout en sachant qu'ils ont une offre de
reprise ça vous le tombe à 499 euros et
j'ai cru comprendre que ces tarifs dans
laquelle on est vouloir la voir tout le
temps donc ça c'est plutôt cool qui fait
que vous avez un smartphone qui est bien
qui est performant qui ont durant à
moins de 500 euros chez au nord avec le
gpu turbo 3 enfin tout ça n'a rien c'est
vraiment cool
je trouve que c'est un bon produit je
sais pas vous ce que vous en pensez
première chose
dites moi en bas en commentaire comment
vous trouvez ce dos un peu violine le
tord peuls comme ça avec ses petits
effets moi j'aime bien vous vous en
pensez quoi
à vos claviers j'aime j'aime pas vous me
dites tout l'été et pourquoi deuxième
point qu'est ce que vous pensez vous
justement est bien de cet petit point
sont alors c'est pas le premier modèle à
d'avoir cette année mais comment vous
trouvez sur ceux au nord 20 pro est ce
que vous trouvez ça bien oui non
intéressant vous marquez tous un banc
commentaire et au final comment vous
trouvez ce produit est ce que vous êtes
plutôt content satisfait par rapport aux
normes un qui était présenté ya pas
longtemps et est ce que c'est un modèle
que vous pourriez acheter pour le
deuxième semestre 2010 9 vous marquez
tout ça que si vous avez des questions
ou interrogations suggestion vous pouvez
y aller à vos claviers c'est juste en
bas voilà sur ce je vous fais des gros
bisous des gros becs
je continue ma petite installation dans
le studio il ya plein de choses qui vont
arriver aux freins studio tour dans
quelques temps tranquillement lâche en
train de l'installer ouais enfin vous
voyez pas moi je vois voyez si vous
n'arrivez à voir le reflet de mes yeux
beaucoup rêvent ya vachement de choses
qui vont se passer ailleurs beaucoup de
nouveauté à la rentrée il ya beaucoup de
trucs hyper cool je pars la semaine
prochaine à chamonix je vous dis on va
parler d'une autre marque de smartphone
on va voyager ou par haberlin laisse
quelques temps plein de trucs super cool
donc si ce n'est pas déjà fait vous
invite dès maintenant à vous abonner
comme ça vous serez tous voilà sortis en
masse à bientôt ciociu